[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle demi heure d'information locale
voici les titres de ce jeudi à 17 mai le
numérique à l'école le département des
yvelines dresse un premier bilan de son
plan lancé il ya trois ans le rôle des
tablettes la place de la robotique dans
les établissements experts enseignants
élus se sont retrouvés pour échanger et
réfléchir à la mise en place d'une
nouvelle politique
une bonne nouvelle pour les amoureux de
golf le numéro un mondial l'américain
justin thomas haas a confirmé qu'il sera
présent à saint quentin en yvelines pour
l'open de france la compétition débutera
le 28 juin prochain longue entretien à
suivre dans ce journal avec le président
de la fédération de golf
invité également cédric guy rouleau
président fondateur de l'académie de
sabre laser de voisins-le-bretonneux
l'académie accueille dont dix jours le
premier tournoi el nacional de combat
sportif de sabre laser quand un art
martial se mélange à la virtualité
vous verrez attention si vous empruntez
les transports en commun pour vous
rendre ou partir de saint quentin en
yvelines demain vendredi
nouvelle journée de grève des cheminots
la sncf prévoit des perturbations moins
important tout de même que lundi dernier
dont le détail comptez 1 train sur 2 sur
la ligne n ai eu du transilien et un
train sur trois sur le rer c les
horaires précis et des trains sont
disponibles notamment sur transilien.com
les premières assises du numérique
éducatif en yvelines se sont tenues
déroulée hier au campus aux mureaux à
450 élus et membres de la communauté
éducative était présent pour l'occasion
objectif faire à un bilan trois ans
après le lancement d'un plan numérique
départementale hall et aurélie rose
était sur place
améliorer le quotidien des élèves et des
équipes pédagogiques grâce aux outils
numériques
en 2015 le département des yvelines a
investi plus de 30 millions d'euros pour
généraliser
et le très haut débit les espaces
numériques de travail ou encore les
tablettes dans les établissements
scolaires pourquoi le numérique c'est
pas simplement un outil pour mieux
apprendre mais c'est aussi pouvoir qu'au
décès pouvoir être le mieux armé dans un
monde où le digital est présent et voir
omniprésent au programme de ces
premières assises des moments d'échangé
de partage et d'expérience mais aussi
des ateliers thématiques comme
l'utilisation de robots dès le plus
jeune âge pour apprendre à lire
ces assises ont également été l'occasion
de pointer du doigt quelques
dysfonctionnements comme le manque de
formation des enseignants pour
l'utilisation des tablettes numériques
mais pas qu on observe aujourd'hui que
la difficulté à toucher des familles qui
sont sur des territoires socialement
plus défavorisés voilà pour nous ça
c'est un vrai enjeu c'est un enjeu
commerçants qui sont pas se poser dès
demain c'est une des difficultés de
l'exercice
comment peut-on évaluer le fait qu'un
certain nombre d'élèves vont apprendre
plus facilement et obtenir de meilleurs
résultats
il faut se donner du temps pour pouvoir
avoir des résultats sur le volet
qualitatif des choses concernant le
volet quantitatif à la rentrée 2010 8
les élèves de 18 collèges heavy noah
seront dotés de tablettes numériques
éducation toujours pour la troisième
fois versailles accueillera dans un peu
plus d'un an le congrès national des
enseignants des écoles et classes
maternelles publiques un événement qui
permettra notamment aux enfants de toute
la france de travailler cette année sur
la très large thématique de la culture
les explications avec ce reportage de
miquel et demi d'euros
un spectacle pour annoncer le 92ème
congrès national des enseignants des
écoles et classes maternelles publiques
le rendez vous sont organisés par
l'association agem en juillet 2019 pour
la cinquième fois dans le département
des yvelines
objectif développer des projets sur
l'année pour les tout petits
dans un premier temps ce sont les
enseignants qui réfléchissent en fait
sur la thématique du congrès et cette
thématique en fait les définit en axe de
travail et après les enseignants de
toute la france peuvent s'emparer d'une
des thématiques et travailler dans la
classe avec les élèves
cette année l'événement proposera aux
enfants de travailler sur le thème ozon
les arrêts seront des graines de culture
avec un seul but développer l'éveil des
enfants en maternelle
un projet soutenu par l'éducation
nationale il est clair que ce thème là
est une façon pour les élèves non
seulement de ceux sur de se socialiser
mais aussi d'apprendre et d'apprendre
peut-être par une façon détournée on
comprend très bien qu'avec de jeunes
enfants
on ne peut pas avoir - avec eux qu'avec
d'autres encore une approche académique
des savoirs et sa découverte du monde sa
découverte de l'autre ces découvertes de
la connaissance peut se faire tout à
fait par les arts les enfants
présenteront ensuite leurs travaux
devant plus de 1200 personnes dont des
parents d'élèves et des spécialistes sur
la maternelle l'événement s'organise et
les 3 4 et 5 juillet en bref une
information plutôt insolite la police
des îles une recherche activement les
propriétaires de deux perotti les
oiseaux ont été trouvées dans le coffre
d'une voiture à elle en cours il ya
quelques jours dans le message diffusé
sur les réseaux sociaux
la police indique ils ont probablement
été volés lors d'un cambriolage
si vous disposez d'informations pour
aider les enquêteurs vous pouvez joindre
le numéro et qui s'affiche sur vos
écrans à l'instant je vous le disais
dans les titres à quelques semaines de
l'épreuve le plateau de l'open de france
de golf commence à se dévoiler et il
devrait il y avoir du beau monde cette
année le français alexander levy a déjà
annoncé sa participation le numéro un
mondiale justin thomass a également
confirmé sa présence sur les greens
saint quentinois à partir du 28 juin
prochain des annonces qui ravissent
forcément le président de la fédération
française de golf jean louis charon
notre journaliste sportif mais quel
ennemi drôle la rencontre et qui
succédera à tommy à fleetwood c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose ici
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en vue de
l'open de france qui se déroulera du 28
juin au 1er juillet à mes côtés
jean-louis charon se pose également la
question alors il y aura un beau plateau
cette année sur cet open de france je
chante effectivement le plateau
s'annonce magnifique puisque nous savons
déjà que le vainqueur l'an dernier sera
présent pour remettre son titre en jeu
tommy fleetwood de misfits ou derrière
vous exactement que comme un clin d'oeil
en signe de cette édition 2018 john ram
a confirmé la présence également et pour
ne plus rien cacher aujourd'hui devrait
annoncer la venue du nouveau numéro un
mondial depuis dimanche à l'issue du
players qui est justin tamas donc un
plateau plutôt conséquente de joueurs de
talents de haut niveau et puis nous
espérons aussi que la présence de ces
trois stars du golf mondial entraînera
d'autres grands noms à venir se joindre
à nous tous pour disputer une édition
2010 8,70 extraordinaire un nom comme
justin thomas ce qu'est ce que ça va
apporter à l'open de france le numéro un
mondial présent à l'open de france donne
encore plus de crédibilité si besoin
était à l'épreuve
justin hamas et ses amis pourraient donc
qu'être présent et donner un éclat tout
particulier pour cette édition 2010 8
et vous pensez qu'il est venu en vue de
la ryder cup qui se déroulera justement
sur le parcours de l'albatros ici à
saint quentin en yvelines en septembre
prochain à mon avis sans aucun doute il
est venu tester le parcours l'europe
kahn est d'une certaine manière et sans
doute
de l'année des points dans classement
pour conforter une position qui est la
sienne et peut-être décrocher pourquoi
pas donc le challenge sera à relever
durant la période du 28 juin au 1er
juillet ça gros plus également au niveau
de la billetterie on se souvient de la
venue de rory mcilroy qui est à l'époque
numéro 3 mondial qui avait boosté
vraiment l es ventes 50 % de ventes en
plus il ya deux ans est ce que vous
pensez qu'il y aura le même effet justin
thomas oui vous avez raison de souligner
l'attractivité du numéro un mondial et
d'autre mais lui john ram et tommy
fleetwood devrait déclencher une
présence accrue des fans de golf sur le
sur l'ogre nationale alors il y aura les
étrangers il y aura également les
français juste un petit bémol il n'y
aura pas victor dubuisson qui sera
blessé pour cette édition c'est un coup
dur pour l'open de france
oui sans aucun doute le talent de victor
nepad a démontré ses problèmes
récurrents santé pèse un peu sur sa
carrière et l'empêchent d'être présent
2018 alors qu'il avait annoncé dès
l'automne 2010 est son souhait de
travailler son globe de concourir pour
être sélectionnable en équipe européenne
de ryder cup et je suis sûr qu'il avait
prévu de venir disputer l'open de france
ensuite ces problèmes d'équilibré
d'oreille interne problèmes qu'a connus
dans passé thomas levet souvenez-vous et
qu'il avait su résoudre problème donc
de santé que victor doit surmonter avant
de je l'espère pour nous tous venir à
nouveau à l'open de france nous montrer
tout son talent il y aura un français un
parcours qui sera bien présent sur les
greens saint quentinois ce alexander
levy qui a gagné un titre cette année au
maroc
est-ce qu alexander levy est favori pour
cette édition 102e édition de l'open de
france sans aucun doute il est parmi les
favoris il nous a montré en gagnant le
trophée hassan ii d'abel manière qu'il
avait su gérer son score son parcours
montée en puissance en quatre jours et
au dernier tour tirer profit de ta
position prendre la tête déjà et gérer
l'ensemble des scores jusqu'au bout donc
alex l'ebit est non seulement candidat
une sélection dans l'équipe européenne
l'open de france est une belle manière
de le démontrer de marquer sa forte
présence et puis d'ajouter un type en
2018 attaque carrière donc parmi les
favoris alex les oui sans aucun doute
figurent sur cette liste
vous pensez que si remporté ici l'open
de france il sera dans l'équipe
européenne en septembre quelques mois
plus tard oui je le pense sont sans
aucun doute de ma part il a comme je le
soulignais montrer à rabat sur parcours
dar es salaam qu'il avait la maîtrise la
capacité de gérer l'épreuve et son tour
une victoire à l'open de france le
qualifierait à mon avis pour une
sélection en équipe européenne c'est
tout le mal qu'on lui souhaite
alors il ya alexander levy mais il peut
y avoir des surprises un côté français
michaël lorenzo-vera avait terminé
notamment troisième égalité l'année
dernière est ce que c'est une
possibilité également de voir un
français s'illustre et en dehors
justement des têtes de série c'est notre
souhait le plus cher en plus ce week end
michael lorenzo-vera père en play off
enfin père pardon de le dire comme ça va
en play off et il s'incline au premier
troc l'herbe mais lui aussi démontre sa
forme sa présence est sans aucun doute
avec alex lévis il fera partie lui aussi
des favoris je dois souligner que le
boeuf français professionnel se porte
très bien puisque le week-end dernier
que ce soit au portugal ou en sicile par
exemple on man aux français dans top 10
près dans combatif actif dans le sens
sportif du terme et qui veulent faire
briller au plus haut niveau
nos couleurs notre pays est leur talent
donc l'open de france à nouveau et le
lieu idéal
en prélude un la ryder cup quelques
semaines plus tard pour démontrer leurs
talents et prouver à quel point la
france est devenue une terme de golf
on l'a compris jean loup un très beau
plateau côté américain un très beau
plateau côté européen et surtout
français
l'open de france ce sera du 28 juin au
1er juillet encore un mot de golf
aujourd'hui était organisé le trophée
sport passion une compétition amicale
organisée depuis 25 ans au mois de mai
sur le golf de feucherolles pour ce
rendez-vous est des dizaines de stars du
monde du sport ont fait le déplacement
pour partager un moment entre amis ou
pour parfaire leur swing quelques
réactions recueillies une nouvelle fois
micro de michael et demi d'euros ça me
tient toujours à coeur de participer au
sport passion parce que ça fait 25 ans
que ça dure et ça doit faire 23 fois que
je viens
quand je les ai ratées c'est parce que
j'étais certainement en contrats aux
états unis
et là maintenant ben voila j'ai un petit
peu plus de temps pour assurer depuis
une dizaine d'années je suis là et je
veux pas le manquer même si aujourd'hui
c'est l'anniversaire de mon épouse
olivia donc on vient ici pour rencontrer
des joueurs qui sont totalement
différents dans d'autres disciplines et
en fait de voir que le golf peut nous
réunir et et nous faire partager des
choses extraordinaires
rendez vous traditionnel du printemps
l'association yvelines environnement
organisé mardi à versailles la remise
des prix de son jeu concours destiné aux
jeunes yvelinois de 5 à 15 ans est la
thématique cette année étaient nos amis
les prairies si le thème change tous les
ans l'objectif lui reste le même
sensibiliser les plus jeunes au
développement durable cette année près
de 800 enfants ont été récompensés et
christine françoise jeanneret la
présidente de l'association était au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
c'est toujours un cru difficile à juger
le jury est toujours très perplexe car
il nous est très difficile quelquefois
de départager les lauréats
car tous ont fait un effort tous ont
bien travaillé et tous mériterait
d'avoir imprimé c'est un concours je
suis donc voila et je pense que
cette année nous avons peut-être plus de
maquettes que nous avions auparavant
et d'ailleurs les maquettes et dessins
des enfants seront exposés c'était cet
été à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet comme l'an passé et puis un
petit bravo tout de même aux écoliers de
jean lurçat à guyancourt qui ont reçu le
premier prix
petits ou grands ils ont facilement
fascine plus d'un la force du sabre
laser s'invita voisins le bretonneux
l'académie de sabre laser locale
organise dans dix jours son premier
tournoi national open de combat sportif
le nom est un peu compliqué mais
l'événement est très sérieux nous allons
en parler avec cédric giroux et non pas
avec guy roux bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le président fondateur de cette académie
de sabre laser à voisins le bretonneux
je le disais on peut être un peu
compliqué pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas cet univers cette galaxie expliqué
yu que va-t-il se passer concrètement
dans dix jours au centre sportif les
pyramides à voisins bretons 9 alors on
va avoir la chance à voisin d'héberger
en fait le premier tournoi national de
combat sportif au sabre laser
pourquoi je dis premier tournoi national
parce que historiquement en fait le
sabre laser était pratiquée par des
clubs plus tôt artistiquement on sait
leur convenait d'événementiel des
prestations chorégraphié mais depuis
quelques années le combat sportif est
arrivée sur le territoire national donc
un sport à la touche avec des lames en
polycarbonate qui sont en fait des
sabres lumineux de l'univers sont aussi
importantes
exactement donc
nous ce qu'on voulait à la création de
l'académie c'était vraiment faire
quelque chose de sécuriser au niveau des
de la pratique sportive du sabre laser
et donc on s'est rapproché de la
fédération française d'escrimé qui
depuis l'année dernière a inclus en fait
le sabre laser dans la pratique de la
fédération et maintenant faisant partie
du groupe de travail du sabre laser ben
voilà la fédération héberge pour la
première fois un premier tournoi
national on voit on a vu quelques images
à l'écran c'est assez impressionnant
alors vous le disiez tournoi c'est à
dire qu'il y aura des poules les
huitièmes de finale quarts dé finale
comment ça se passe concrètement un
tournoi de sabre laser alors un tournoi
de sabre laser on a voulu que ça soit un
petit peu différent de ce que les scream
faisait en fait donc il ya effectivement
deux catégories qui vont être utilisés
les deux catégories en fait
correspondent à des épaisseurs de l'âme
le lam on peut la carbonade qu'on
utilisait plus ou moins épaisses donc là
en fait il ya des catégories avec des
lames plus ou moins légère selon le
niveau aussi non pas forcément là c'est
vraiment en fait comme si le première
nationale on a invité au niveau de la
fédération tous les clubs participants
qu'ils soient et fait feu ou non et fait
feu à dire que c'est un open où tous les
clubs tous les clubs pardon participants
et pratiquant le sabre laser peuvent
venir et donc on a ce qu'on appelle une
formule qu est ce qu est une formule où
les gens vont se rencontrer on a
développé une application ios android
spécial pour cette occasion la nos qui
aura une nouvelle formule qui font que
les gens vont avoir un certain
classement en fonction des matchs qui
vont réaliser
alors on vous a déjà reçu plusieurs fois
sur ce plateau on a fait plusieurs
reportages avec vous on voit que cette
pratique est très sérieuse il ne s'agit
pas d'une lubie de certains fanatiques
un peu un peu rêveur s'éteint c'est un
vrai sport là le fait que vous soyez
soutenu et ce partenariat se met en
place concrètement avec la fédération
française d'escrimé est ce que ça fait
franchir à la pratique du sabre laser
une nouvelle étape avec ce tournoi
notamment
oui il est vraiment la réflexion qui
avait été fait au niveau de la
fédération c'était de pouvoir encadrer
d'une certaine façon la pratique du
sabre laser encore une fois à part du
moment on fait du sport et on fait du
sport compétitif il faut quand même
rester dans une certaine norme au niveau
de la loi sportive française qui est
quand même assez encadrée et du coup la
fédération vous les actes et les choses
s'est normalisée en fait les protections
surtout au niveau de la pratique du
sabre laser norman il est normalisée
larmes et pouvoir offrir à des jeunes a
déjà deux maîtres d'armes
une possibilité de devenir en fait
pratiquement deux sabres laser ouvrir
une section sabre laser dans le reste et
puis rappelons que les encadrants comme
vous sont des professionnels des arts
martiaux
je n'ai pas de wii alors moi j'ai c'est
vrai que je suis fan de la saga
effectivement j'ai pratiqué mois les
arts martiaux plutôt japonais avec une
école de sabre japonaise
mais c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
de nouveau niveau de la fédération
c'est une ouverture d'esprit en fait
parce que c'est vrai que les maîtres
d'armes étaient plus ou moins formés aux
trois armes fleuret sabre et épée et là
maintenant avec l'arrivée du sabre laser
ces nouvelles opportunités de développer
cette pratique est de la faire
reconnaître comme un vrai sport alors ce
tournoi en question il est réservé à
ceux qui pratiquent déjà le sabre laser
mais ceux qui veulent aussi qu'ils sont
curieux peuvent venir il ya d'autres
animations prévues le dimanche 27 mai
c'est ça on pourra notamment assister au
promis à une première des combats au
sabre laser en équipe et alors je
voudrais avoir une petite précision
puisque j'ai lu précisément sur le site
internet qu'il y aura l'utilisation
éventuelle de pouvoir des pouvoirs de la
force
alors rassurez nous il n'y a pas de
magicien de sorcier d'être présent non
non pour faire un très vite topo au
niveau de la
de la convention il y aura une
convention ludique avec des jeux liés à
l'univers star wars des cosplayeurs des
animations
un orchestre de cuivres aussi qui sera
là à la fin de la journée et
parallèlement à ça on a donc le
championnat qui sera en place
et dans ce tournoi effectivement fait
des petites nouveautés c'est à dire que
pour le moment la fédération actes et du
combat en individuel mais on essaie de
développer ça avec effectivement du
conte en équipe qui est plus proche du
grandeur nature avec des gestuelles pour
lancer des programmes et celle qu'on
peut voir dans la saga star wars et ses
séquelles qui s'en rapproche un peu plus
un petit peu plus loin donc du coup le
27 mai c'est pour les pratiquants du
sabre laser mais aussi ceux qui sont
curieux bien sûr pas ceux qui aiment
l'univers ce qui peut passer du bon
temps ce qui vous voir des spectacles
des choses un petit peu sympa il y aura
des enfants des adultes on court et ça
devrait être sympa
et pour vous inscrire ou avoir plus de
renseignements c'est sur le site
internet académie du académie de sabre
laser point fr on voit le site
s'afficher en bas de l'écran exactement
merci beaucoup cédric giroud pour toutes
ces précisions d'être venus aussi sur le
plateau vous êtes le président fondateur
de l'académie de sabre laser à voisins
le bretonneux merci beaucoup merci
un autre univers désormais qui peut lui
aussi faire rêver beaucoup de personnes
celui de cannes et du cinéma quatrième
épisode de la rédaction de tv 78 autour
des yvelinois présent sur la croisette
pendant le festival
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse à des
étudiants de 3e d'elancourt qui ont
réalisé un court métrage
ils viennent pour la première fois
forcément à cannes reportage de grégory
canale et alexis à garneau
participer au festival de cannes un rêve
pour beaucoup et notamment pour les
étudiants de cinéma décrocher une
accréditation accéder au palais et aux
projections deux étudiants de 3e à
elancourt l'institut de l'image et du
son font partie est des privilégiés au
short film corner l'espace et des courts
métrages françois auteur et edward
agents ont inscrit dolores maria
[Musique]
françois edouard vous cosigné donc vous
co réalisé le court métrage dolores
marie a de quoi parle ce court métrage
est alors c'est l'histoire de quatre
kidnappeurs plus ou moins d'eau et qui
vont enlever maria dolores qui pensent
enlevé marée de leur est la fille d'un
banquier et qu'ils vont finalement levée
de leur est marié à la fille d'un
monsieur pourquoi avoir choisi cet angle
mais qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à
parler de ça ce qui nous a poussé à
parler de ça donc c'est bah c'est
surtout le travail sur le genre on
voulait s'attaquer à un film particulier
et donc qu'ils sont bien connus et
connotés dans le final cinéma et est un
peut s'inspirer de tout ce qui nous fait
vibrer dans le cinéma personnellement
est ce qu'on aime voir et ressentir en
tant que spectateur parce qu'on apprend
c'est au spectateur en premier voilà
puisque vous pouvez apporter le film
comme émotion c'est votre premier
festival à tous les deux oui c'est notre
premier festival reçoit également oui
c'est la première fois qu'on participe à
un festival très bien qu'est ce que ça
représente pour un étudiant de troisième
en option cinéma en audiovisuel ce que
ça représente d'être ici c'est une
formidable opportunité de faire des
rencontres
premièrement de aussi de lancer dans le
bain de ce métier de l'univers du monde
du cinéma et je pense que
voilà je pense que c'est une opportunité
extraordinaire pour vous françois ouais
c'est un secret pour personne que les
contacts sont très importants dans le
milieu du cinéma surtout pour les jeunes
cinéastes comme c'est important de
rencontrer du monde est de présenter son
travail pour pouvoir peut-être trouvé
des collaborations justement ça sera ma
dernière question quel est le programme
sur place vous avez prévu peut-être
quelques rendez-vous et pour faire du
business peut-être il ya quelques rendez
vous qu'ils s'organisent justement dans
le cadre du championnat
corner qui nous permettent de rencontrer
des professionnels
dans la production même dans l'écriture
pour nos prochains projets qu'on est en
train comme nous sommes en train de
développer ces rencontres et et même par
hasard parfois on rencontre parfois dans
les soirées parfois au détour d'une rue
de rencontrer des producteurs et tout ça
donc c'est plutôt futée enrichissant
comme expérience et on vous souhaite un
bon festival merci françois edouard
merci bien sûr
[Musique]
le film du jour subventionnées par la
région ile de france et réalisé par
l'italien stefano savona et chamonix
road prend forme dans la périphérie de
gaza où une famille s'apprête à célébrer
un mariage
la première fait depuis longtemps après
les ravages de la guerre contre israël
[Musique]
enfin chez de madère où la valve on
quitte est la croisette retour dans les
yvelines heures rendez-vous demain pour
la clôture de cannes 78
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de l'avoir suivi cette édition est
disponible en replay sur notre site
internet où l'application tv et 78 tout
de suite vous retrouvez le 7-8 débat
pour évoquer la situation économique
dans le département des yvelines
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]